et bien c'est assez étonnant
instinctivement on aurait pu croire que
les gens ne se déplacerait pas pour
cette collecte de sang et des plaquettes
c'est tout le contraire ici à
rambouillet il ya une queue comme si
c'était un commerce alimentaire tout le
monde respecte les règles sanitaires en
respectant un mètre ou deux mètres pour
la queue et puis évidemment à
l'intérieur toutes les règles aussi
sanitaires et d'hygiène sont respectées
tout le personnel pour la collecte est
équipé d'un masque de grands et donc
beaucoup de monde des gens rassurer à
l'intérieur du fait de toutes ces de
toutes ces règles
selon les chiffres de le fs6 les stocks
ne sont pas mauvais aujourd'hui il
pourrait l'être du fait du confinement
c'est pour cela qu'ils appellent les
gens à se mobiliser
les produits sanguins ont une durée de
vie très limitée 7 jours pour les
plaquettes et 42 pour les globules
rouges donc s'il n'y a pas d'inquiétude
aujourd'hui pour l y en avoir dans 15 ou
20 jours si le confinement se poursuit
il faut donc rester absolument mobilisés
pour cela rien de compliqué il faut
s'équiper de cette fameuse dérogation
que vous connaissez désormais très bien
et cochez la troisième case celle qui
mentionne un déplacement pour motifs de
santé
si vous avez ça sur vous toute légalité
aucun problème pour aller donner votre
sang c'est très important pour savoir où
se tiendra les prochaines collectes dans
les yvelines et près de chez vous un
site internet dont 200 points fs pointe
sante.fr des collectes sont notamment
prévus à feucherolles dans les yvelines
vendredi à saint germain les châteaux
forts et saint rémy les chevreuse la
semaine prochaine restez donc mobilisés